hasta esta hora según los resultados a
Boca de urna se produce un empate
técnico entre los candidatos Rafael
López aliaga con un 26.8%, y Daniel
urresti con un
25.8%. según la encuestadora ipsos esta
situación le otorga a renovación popular
partido de López aliaga un importante
número de alcaldías en la capital
peruana debemos señalar que estos
resultados parciales están ubicando en
último lugar a Perú libre agrupación
política del presidente Pedro Castillo
que hasta el momento según los este
resultado parciales está obteniendo un
1.2% de los votos la campaña política de
esta agrupación no pudo sintonizar con
los electores diversos analistas están
señalando que las acusaciones se
presunta corrupción contra el presidente
Pedro Castillo le están pasando una
factura muy cara a sus correligionarios
Francisco así las cosas Entonces cómo se
espera que sea la proyección para el
resto del país esto que alcance puede
tener
la encuestadora Epson se está señalando
que el Lima existe una pugna entre la
Ultra a la derecha y la centro derecha
mientras que en el resto del país son
los candidatos independientes los
movimientos locales quienes van a
derrotar a los partidos tradicionales
porque señalan que el electorado los
peruanos están molestos con su clase
política por el constante enfrentamiento
que tienen en los partidos se agrupados
en el congreso peruano y quienes están
en un constante enfrentamiento con el
gobierno del presidente Pedro Castillo
esto les está pasando una factura además
de diversos hechos de corrupción que se
han ido presentando a lo largo de los
meses los analistas también están
Estableciendo que es muy probable que en
algunas regiones los electores tengan
que acudir a un segundo balotaje Porque
todavía las cifras no están definidas y
hay muchas
divi y debemos señalar que hay un alto
índice de peruanos que a última hora
decidieron su voto porque el descontento
que existe en la mayor parte de la
población los resultados oficiales de
estos comicios regionales y municipales
en Perú recién se van a conocer a partir
de las 10 de la noche Y desde ahí en
adelante vamos a ver cómo queda pintado
el nuevo mapa político de este país